in Lebanon roads are being blocked in
the capital as part of a 12th day of
demonstrations on Sunday tens of
thousands formed a human chain
stretching almost the entire length of
the coastline from north to south
there's anger over corruption and
mismanagement of the economy Stephanie
Decker is in Beirut it is day 12 and
people remain on the streets blocking
the roads this is one of the main
highways through Beirut it's one of the
tactics the protesters are employing to
keep the pressure on the government now
there's almost a community feel here a
lot of people sitting around actually if
we can ask one of these ladies why are
you here well hi how are you what do you
what are you trying to achieve by being
here she's gonna what are we trying to
achieve we're trying to we want to have
known to design and we're trying to
prove a point here that we're not gonna
leave the streets till delete til they
leave what do you want from them what do
you want in your life to change basic
human rights we want to go we want to be
able to use hospitals we want basic
basic things to be able to not not have
to wait two and three jobs just to be
able to finish uni and that's a basic
basic human rights that's all we want
thank you that's a very similar message
that everyone here and also in other
cities across Lebanon are calling for
basic human rights the economy here the
fact people are siting there are no jobs
electricity waters these basic things
there is also a lot of humor here and
you can see they've set up what is
almost like a makeshift living room
there's a fridge people are talking
they've been debating throughout the
days here and of course this is putting
a lot of pressure not everyone is happy
about it we've seen some of the
roadblocks we've seen some cars very
frustrated trying to break through the
protesters will charge to the cars also
to yell peaceful peaceful but it is
causing havoc on the roads it is causing
those people who want to move around the
city a lot of stress and of course
schools remain closed the banks remain
closed and this is one of the main
challenges going ahead it's the last
week of the month payday is coming out
people
are questioning how that is all going to
work out certainly at the moment there
is no resolve it seems to be a stalemate
the people are remaining on the streets
the government isn't resigning and at
the moment nobody can tell you how
that's all going to play out